-We're gonna do commercial
for, like, local anchors.
-For like three more hours
-Yeah.
It's super fun.
-They -- Oh, my God.
This is the best part.
They love it.
-I love this.
-I actually do like this.
-You do?
-'Cause I goof with you
a little bit,
and I enjoy it.
-Yeah, you do goof a little bit.
But, like, I got to say
that the best joke
at the Golden Globes --
Three Shoes.
-Beverly Jackfruit? Three Shoes.
Guess who wrote Three Shoes?
"Tinald" Fey.
Tina Fey.
-Gosh. "Tinald" -- "Tinald" Fey.
Three Shoes is the funnies
thing ever.
-She was like -- I was hoardin
that shoe for so long.
-It's the funniest joke
at the Golden Globes.
Maya was a character
and came out with Kenan.
-Her name is Beverly Jackfruit
'cause --
-And you were just so excited,
but then also,
you wanted to
take your shoes off?
-Yeah.
Well, she wanted to
get comfortable.
You got to get comfortable
-So she took her shoes off
and she handed it to Amy,
and Amy played it perfectly.
She's like, "Yeah," and then
you gave her three shoes.
-Yeah.
-She goes, "Somehow
there's a third shoe."
-She has three feet.
-That was the funniest thing
man. I loved it.
Gosh, it was so funny.
Maya Rudolph is here tonight
Plus we have
Christopher Meloni,
Music from 24kGoldn,
and Tariq Trotter shares
his latest irk list.
It's a great show
right after you guys.
[ Scatting ]
-I know --
-[ Scatting ]
♪♪♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Stammering ]
[ Scatting ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Trills ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love how she gets surprised
by it.
-She surprised herself.
-She's like, "Bup!"
-You know why?
'Cause something popped.
-[ Laughing ] Okay!